hmm we know it doesn't get any scarier
than us
frontierbundles.com surveyed which state
prefers
which scary villain for the past year
and here are the results
frankenstein claimed the highest amount
of searches with 11 states
searching him the most ghostface from
the 90s cult movie
scream came in second with eight states
favoring him
as the most scary villain including our
state of nevada
and he might be almost 32 years old now
but
chucky the good guys doll rounds up to
the top three most popular horror movie
villains
with seven states choosing his scary
sweetness
over others while the movie killed it at
the box office bringing in over 400
million dollars
only four states favored the it villain
pennywise which was kindle earlier yes
yep
oh it was bad sadly me
freddy krueger and pinhead over here did
not make the cut which i don't
understand
how we're so scary you guys
are frightening i mean if one of you
were when they were mentioning denise
driving into work today
i mean you've caused some accidents yeah
oh we're actually gonna go down to
fremont street tonight make some money
taking pictures five dollars a photo
we're working tonight yes
yes by the way for our viewers that's
rocky theis there as freddy krueger and
jc fernandez there
as pinhead well done how long did the
makeup take oh
um hour and a half yeah because right
here right here
yeah oh yeah can you see yeah it looks
great good job you guys like the detail
the details
and also skin city they did an excellent
job
yeah it's on your twitter addresses each
of you right where the whole group of
you yeah
together yeah it was good it was real
good
so if our viewers missed it earlier
that's where they can check it out as
well you guys look fantastic we hope you
don't
scare anybody tonight and maybe keep
those costumes for tomorrow you're going
to drive home last night i'm going to
sleep
i'm going to sleep right now yeah yeah
i sleep like this so i don't mess up my
makeup so she can wear it again tomorrow
yeah on point yeah why not